now before we explore touch support in
detail it's important to understand that
you may not even need to do anything in
order to support touch touch events
emulate mouse clicks already and the web
browser builds in some gestures like
scrolling and zooming
so you only need to implement something
here in cases where the built-in gesture
support or mouse emulation does not give
an optimal user experience
in fact for most of our conference app
we don't use touch or pointer events
ourselves at all the built-in mouse
emulation works great for clicking on
items and it's only buried inside the
session schedule and the map that touch
is handled directly